so
I figured I've been asking for advice
um
and
you know about training and going to the
gym and stuff like that and I figured
bro Royce you're being so stupid you
have access to one of the best workout
people in the world right at your
fingertips every single day everyone's
favorite Black Market steroid buying in
person he Trenton way did not do
anything to you and I will not let you
talk about them like that wasn't about
being gay lion oh yeah that's fine [ __ ]
that guy
um so
iCarly I love Trenton Mark Harley
um
has we've always brought up how he saw
he should just cut the t-o-t-o-n out of
his name
wait
Trend and D ball Wade
um Trend evil trendy ball Wade [ __ ] I
don't care that guy's [ __ ] an animal
he's so [ __ ] Rich you can see
striations or striations everywhere
anyway Trenton wait wow so we talk about
Mark Harley wanting to
he wants to be sex with men so he's
constantly running from those thoughts
that's why I live so much he's pushing
the Gay Thoughts away pushing him over
and over
get out of my head anyway big a lion
used to have a big hit workout show did
you big gay know that I did not big gay
know that okay well so we got a big gay
clip of it oh we do have a big gay clip
[Music]
oh sorry I I apologize I apologize I
apologize he's the one on the left oh
thank you you're welcome
what's up my name is Mark Harley I'm an
actor personal trainer and strength and
conditioning coach you're maybe one of
those things and also your left tit has
gyno you're absolutely a personal
trainer your left kid has gyno
based here in Los Angeles California I
have been in love with resistance
trainings
ooh injection spot that happens
sometimes
he injects in the delts since the age of
13 when I first stepped in a gym and
started lifting weights high intensity
interval training now keep in mind
this is something else he's tried to do
when the comedy didn't work out and the
podcasting doesn't work out he's a
personal trainer and he has always been
a great match for me and the sports that
I was pretty do you think Brendan keeps
him around because he's the only guy
that's failed at more stuff than him
foreign
wow you might be right like he's
Brendan's he's Brendan's Brendan yeah oh
my God you're right he's the only one
that Brennan could pick on yeah and
Brendan can feel like a winner around he
takes the heat off of him
um
also hey uh I I also shop on Amazon is
that that's that knee list that Amazon
brand you know what that is right it's
that Amazon brand yeah pursuing whether
that's competitive swimming you get
anything in there you go on the old
Black Friday there doing what you're
gonna be getting on the old Black Friday
what do you mean
on Amazon oh yeah I'm gonna check it out
I mean I already bought about hold on
but here's the thing I already bought a
bunch of [ __ ] I didn't even wait for
Black Friday I think about sales but
here's the thing I hope they have good
sales because like last year the sales
was like we have sales if you like
Amazon products Honestly though look now
okay I'll check it out honestly the
Amazon tvser I just bought Amazon TV
okay
high school wrestling playing football
in college it all translated really well
uh did you notice something version he
didn't miss he didn't mention San
Francisco comedy College
he might not have gotten his degree at
this point oh this is when he was still
okay you're right yeah he's still in
yeah he might be in his last semester
yeah he was one haha credit away from
graduating
that's what they call it there because
it's not they're not accredited they're
not their credit at school yeah you
can't call them actual credits no no
after I graduate that's why comedies is
in quotation marks on the billboard in
college I became a certified strength
and conditioning specialist yes I could
go online my fat ass could go online and
become a certified strength conditioning
coach it's like a 10 question thing
online yeah
National strength and conditioning
Association and began working one-on-one
as a personal trainer with clients and
also working with local sports teams now
I'm just a buff guy that people stop on
the street to ask for workout advice oh
is that it is that what you are
really because you look like a deeply
causative homosexual beta who's doing
everything he can to not realize that
he's untalented and should be working at
some sort of Jiffy Lube and selling
steroids after work
but [ __ ] cool it's cool he's right
hey he is cool okay you guys see what
you want he's a cool guy
[ __ ] [ __ ] dork that advice no but
here's what you think bro honestly and
just didn't think of Brandon but I'll
stay with him look really good shape say
what you want he's in fantastic shapes
their originality is in great shape okay
how can you
look like this physically and have me
and him feel bad for you like I pity you
like
you're so dumb it's it's it really
because we talk about this all the time
now people are picking up on it in the
comments I've seen in the clip Channel
where people like you know you guys
mentioned Like You cover Mark Harley
more than Brendan did you like covering
Mark Hardy more than Brandon's shop I
didn't see it before but like I see it
now like I look forward to Mark Harley's
stuff because you're such a dumb guy and
it's not that you're dumb because
there's a lot of dumb people there's a
lot of dumb people that got into [ __ ]
power George Bush but it's Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan there's a lot of [ __ ] stupid
people they got in the power but they
have some kind of like it Factor that's
something that you don't have you know
Mark Carlson it's called Talent yes but
no it's like Mark Carly is one of those
guys like you know what he reminds me of
he reminds me of one of those like like
like when you look at them physically
like perfect example of what looks like
he'd be a perfect pro wrestler yes and
then you see him cut a promo and dark
and you're like man that guy's got a
great look he's never going to go and
then he paralyzes biggie but you know
what I mean it's like it's you go uh
this guy just sucks man it's a shame
because uh like there's certain
wrestlers that come out every once in a
while and go like um big Cass okay it's
a good example you look at him and go
man that guy's got the look he moves
fast he's scary but like he's got like
he's got rabbit buck teeth and then like
when you let him near a microphone it's
like oh boy oh no
he wants that he wants to be everything
and nothing you know
but just having prevention being tall
having muscles and still just being like
the least interesting dude in a room
right right right
hey man [ __ ] it could be worse you could
be a [ __ ] Euro trash 19 year old
that's still [ __ ] holding a grudge
and can't stop watching us workout
advice lucky for you I'm here to share
all my knowledge and experiences and by
the way you might think I'm talking
about you but I'm talking about the
other guy work out wisdom that have
accumulated over the last few decades to
help you reach your fitness goals as
efficiently as possible and you know it
all sucks if you're Mark Carly right
you live in L.A so you're not even like
special
right like if you lived in Cleveland and
looked like that you know he lived in
like Kenosha Wisconsin you'd be like a
[ __ ] Kenosha 10. you live in L.A do
people really stop you for workout
advice you probably look like every
third guy in L.A yeah good point
the method is as efficient as it gets
the bottom method was originally
developed by a guy named doctor Izumi
Tabata at the National Institute of
fitness and Sports in Tokyo I refuse to
believe that's a real thing yeah of
course I mean Mark Harley's saying it
has he ever lied yeah okay there's a
form of high intensity interval training
that uses a format of 20 seconds of work
followed by 10 seconds of rest which is
designed to increase your aerobic and
anaerobic capacity as efficiently as
the thing with him is is like it's the
pseudo-intellectual talk that really
like well that's what gets under my skin
because like I pointed out earlier
there's a lot of stupid people that's
fine he's probably just reading a men's
health [ __ ] article but not even here
me he is bodybuilding.com trust me yeah
yeah I mean he's just doing the basic
Wiki for like a thing you know like
right sound smart which is fine but but
it's every show he does every time he
talks everything he says
he's somebody who doesn't belong trying
to fit in you understand what I'm saying
like let's overcome that sort over
compensating right he's he's over
compensating his language because in his
brain he knows he's stupid you know
it's not even that he's stupid that bugs
me it's it's like you said how fake he
is yeah so it's like you're presenting a
front instead of just trying to figure
out who you are
you're just like I'm Gonna Keep
pretending the way I'm Gonna Keep
pretending to be things I think people
want me to be so I could be cool instead
of just trying to figure out what you
want to come on Tick Tock getting IG
stories
there is a National Institute of fitness
and Sports in Japan but it's like on a
totally different Island like it's far
away from Tokyo as you possibly could be
no you know where it's located on the
melted that nuclear reactor it's right
next to it
actually it's kind of close I figured it
would be oh great we're gonna have
radioactive super athletes no
radioactive super Harleys which is
[ __ ] way worse glowing big gay Lions
yeah so did he just see Japan and just
added Tokyo look he's an idiot it's all
Tokyo haters will say my sign is crooked
but when you go you weren't gonna meet
me and you know knock him at the time
you're both famous and beautiful and she
was with her friend Brittany babe who I
also follows also sort of famous and
beautiful in these you know worlds that
we Traverse Fitness influencing I hate
him see what I mean worlds that we
Traverse in Fitness influing what
Fitness influencing why do you have to
do that
I I just don't understand it you know
what I mean yeah like you probably they
were really gonna talk like this which
is the most annoying thing
awesome to me they were really nice and
sweet and even uh you know
recognized me I guess people would come
up to me and be like oh I you know she
said specifically I see you everywhere
and I was like oh my God honey stop but
it is cool to be recognized for stuff
like that we're just insecure white
piece of [ __ ] but who recognizes you
mark who us us because we we as you uh
let's use his language because we
Traverse the retards the [ __ ]
hellscape that is YouTube that's why we
come across you the only every time
somebody sees you they the only thing
they they go like oh my God is that a is
that an anamorph
or not even that be like oh look it's
Lionel it's a Thundercat there must be a
show here like nobody looks at you gay
Lino yeah
[Laughter]
Thundercats oh Thundercats hoes slay
chitara
Thundercats let's go break some hearts
and then these boots are made from walk
it starts playing
oh Mark Don't You Ever Change also he's
just so insecure wow you I remember like
watch Royce say oh wait are you merch
I've seen your show before hey man hey
are you immersed I think I've seen your
show before oh [ __ ] yeah man thank you
so much that's so [ __ ] cool we're
gonna suck your dick no please I'd
rather not okay but then it's just like
hey what are you guys drinking hey get
that guy over there thank you so much
shake the honey Lee I've never in my
life been like
you you've seen my show quite
the opposite if people ever recognize
merchand I would go to Adventure New
York or someone recognizes our office is
like really yeah you're like oh [ __ ]
cool thanks dude appreciate it well me
oh [ __ ] oh wait here it is okay we got
it thank you thank you
oh he's such an [ __ ] haters will say
he's an animorph
so this is an hour episode does he ever
get to McDonald's uh-huh no he doesn't
rather just eat some McDonald's no no he
has to get his uh his Silk Road delivery
[ __ ] stingrays
like oh yes we do stuff in the same
space and I don't think about how much
space I hate these people I hate their
way of talking it's bizarre human
reaches people since I do all these
SketchUp with Isaiah come on Tick Tock
and IG stories and how well they do it's
not always something I'm
super caught up with but it was cool
should be all right by now to be like
hey you oh you know me because I know
you and then I'm like come on my podcast
and they're like that's not such a dude
honestly I [ __ ] hate your life like I
I would [ __ ] I would hate your life
like all these I hate my life but I
would hate yours way worse I mean I do
hate my life but compared to yours I I'm
a happy boy and the [ __ ] we make fun of
about you guys I know you're gonna call
us haters let's say we're in fact we're
so super jelly of your life but honestly
living in a town where everyone has a
podcast or runs at night at a comedy
club on a Tuesday like living in a town
like that is [ __ ] me that sounds
miserable yeah I don't want to go out at
night and meet a bunch of people that
are like oh yeah come on the Pod bro oh
I know you don't do it I know you're
kidding please stop you don't want to
see the pot I hate the party I want to
be around that and you love that like
you la [ __ ] love that [ __ ] I that
sounds like a nightmare to me I'm not
even kidding you I wouldn't want that in
my life when I did stand up you know who
I barely hung out with other Comics yeah
like you'd see them on the like when you
do shows you go out for like drinks or
go to a diner afterwards but you weren't
like a football Sunday you were like
let's get a bunch of comedians or
podcasters together you're like just can
we just give regular friends there's a
handful of people that are podcasters
that I consider friends outside of that
I don't really don't want anymore and
even that if they wanted to just hang
out all the time and talk about the
[ __ ] talk shop on the weekend I'd go
it's no no
um
yeah so
hopefully that see what I do is I
instead of instead of talking shop see
what I do is I get a call from Alex
Stein saying his [ __ ] car was towed
a couple miles from my house and instead
of meeting up at McDonald's for
breakfast before he goes to Tampa to do
something I had to try [ __ ] 20 miles
my favorite part of that was and he's
priority told the story but was so yes
his car was towed and then I I drove him
up you know to a tow truck place and in
the back of course he's bitching going I
[ __ ] told the car which he's right
because he [ __ ] did and then for no
reason so then anyway when he gets there
bro
they tell him on the phone because I was
in the car would be 260 right no no 220
right when he gets there and he goes
inside the guy's late by the way we're
standing outside waiting
the guy changed it to 260 40 bucks
morning and all I heard on the outside
was [ __ ] you are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you wait for you when he goes
hey film this and I was like I mean I
guess but if a [ __ ] and I'm screaming
and then he goes you know what I'll give
you the money give me my cards give me
my [ __ ] car so he gives him his car
and he gets it and then the guy to be a
dick you know what he does
you're lucky I didn't charge you 300
that's how much my boss wanted to charge
you just one last parting shot
oh anyway sorry forgot it I forgot about
that that's welcome to Florida yeah
that's Florida man
happens and again just people agreeing
to it I take that as its own thing you
were nice to be a person you agreed to
come on my show
it's separate from can we organize that
you know I'm going to take that as that
was a cool interaction separately who
thinks that way what are you a robot
that was a cool interaction I can't wait
to Traverse the podcasting landscape to
figure out what podcast is space I
apologize podcasting space
um so I can figure out the the
intricacies of the of the verbal of the
verbal art form that we bro [ __ ] stop
come on man
I'll try to arrange it and by the way
it's not that we're too stupid it's not
we're too stupid to get what you're
saying it's just we're too smart to
think that you're smart
the logistics of you that's what it is
the show but that's a separate thing so
I can take that if it never happens
because transcript he doesn't even talk
about McDonald's until like the last two
minutes of this video and it's like a
passing bucket good stall
you know what that's called
you know that's come that's called
teasing him yes this is really like he
does with his hair he teases it
Chuck Norris Gun Club yo dude this is
your show when does it get interesting
wait um
I'm sorry we're doing our best we're
doing our best which dude okay that's
the question how much money do you think
we would have to give him to have Mark
Carly get a perm
like just one of those big like old lady
perms with his hair actually no we don't
have to pay him any money 50 Cent just
has to ask him to do it and he'll do it
because he'll [ __ ] get on his knees
because you know anything for that huh
honestly I think you just get you you
get enough chicks to Gaslight him into
thinking it's cool you don't even have
to pay them you really think it's that
easy with him yeah I think everything
about him is artificial if you could
convince him that perming your hair was
cool again like he would be doing it
within a week it was funny because I saw
a video of this guy called more plates
more dates he's actually yeah I know
that guy okay not personally but he's
very science-based about his [ __ ] like
he's really really smart did you see him
breaking down Mark Carly's [ __ ] thing
like the steroid thing like he just
broke him down I was like I mean all
right but man like because Mark Hurley
this is something the effect of like you
could take a bunch of steroids and not
die and he's like I wouldn't be telling
people that like you know it was like I
don't know if that's actually true yeah
there's more plates more dates does give
you advice on some of the novels no he
doesn't tell you not doing things yeah
but he just tells you safe Safe America
basically he does the smart thing he
goes here's what I do
exactly exactly you know if he's doing
it it looks like it's work he's the one
I got my hair stuff uh figured yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because I was because he
was losing hair like a [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
the goal here
being Bluff and incredibly handsome
right now is great but I hate I'm done
let's go home I'm going home
are you happy are you happy now you
ended the show you happy
Mark I'm going home
but at the end of the day you know you
want to increase that Health span so
that I don't need assistance getting off
the toilet when I'm 65.
yeah when you really look at it yeah 39
and I blew my back out doing deadlifts
with 75 pounds
this is why we can't have nice gyms
why is he screaming at us now I don't
know
I saw this video and I was like there's
just one of these guys in every gym and
how do you know because he's wearing the
immediate climbing of diabetic seizures
look okay forget about Carly first I do
think that like commenting on Jim's
stuff's usually hack protective this is
something I would call you guys hold on
what's he holding 150s is that what he's
holding yeah and he's using every hiking
boots he's using every it's like holy
[ __ ] can I say he's actually impressive
because he's he's doing like four
terrible forms
in one moment the lifting belt it's
amazing right he's doing like four
terrible things in one motion it's
impressive his ability to do things
in a bad way
his legs are as skinny shut up Mark I
just want to see this
I just mute him when we just watch this
yeah dude he's swinging his entire body
elbows his hips his lower back he's
swinging every vulnerable part of the
body dude and meanwhile I have I have to
[ __ ] ease back out of the gym because
my elbow hurts and I was doing better
than that guy as far as form
Jesus yeah not great
all right uh I think we're done with
this idiot we're gonna start going back
to the gym and using a little weights
like an old lady it'll grow it we'll
grow it Barbie ones little pink ones
they're still Black come on yeah that's
the only thing that turns them on the
color all right guys
[Music]